bonjour à tous si vous faites partie du
groupe millions 5 d'étudiants inscrits à
l'université française
bonjour aussi si vous n'en faites pas ou
plus partie ou si vous attendez toujours
que par course ultra ce votre voix on
aime tout le monde ici bref parlons peu
parlons universités
[Musique]
jusqu'au 2ème siècle l'éducation et est
surtout possible via les écoles
monastique qui formait les futurs moine
mais aussi quelques laïcs directement
dans les monastères
on trouvait aussi des rares écoles
publiques créé en 1129 et les écoles
cathédrale qui servent à éduquer les
futurs claire du royaume les nobles
préfère éduquer leurs enfants à domicile
et les villageois reste majoritairement
analphabète a besoin de savoir les peler
pour serrer une charrette
c'était le résumé le plus rapide de six
siècles d'éducation que jamais vu alors
qu'à mon époque les écoles antique
fournissait un enseignement très complet
willy mais on est au 12e siècle là après
le but ici n'est pas de vous résumer
toute l'histoire de l'éducation au
moyen-âge parce que ça serait très long
mais de vous présenter l'apparition des
universités comme le titre l'indiqué au
début du deuxième siècle donc on trouve
surtout à paris des écoles cathédrale la
plus réputée et dans celle
ces écoles sont sous le contrôle de
l'évêque on les retrouve sur l'île de la
cité où les maîtres enseigne la
théologie l'écriture sainte le chant le
latin on reste sur des enseignements
très cloisonné pour futurs clair même si
les élèves les plus doués peuvent
demander à apprendre les arts libéraux
et se spécialiser dans la douche à
leysin libéraux c'est mon domaine
il s'agit dans l'ensemble de matières
elles étaient des écoles antique les
meilleurs parmi elles on trouve le tri
view composer de la grammaire la
rhétorique et la dialectique attribuons
parce qu'il ya trois matières et le quad
review composé de l'arithmétique la
géométrie la musique et l'astronomie à
un quad review basket pendant compris
ces arts libéraux réapparaissent
lentement dans l'éducation à partir du
neuvième siècle
il faut préciser aussi que la grammaire
n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et consiste plutôt en de
l'explication texte au début du 12e
siècle l'île de la cité et donc peuplée
de jeunes claire étudiants des jeunes
etc these stick quoi de leurs maîtres
le tout sous la supervision de l'évêque
mais certains décident alors de saper
cette autorité en partant s'installer
sur la rive gauche près de la montagne
sainte-geneviève et de la rue saint
jacques
c'est le cas de pierre abélard par
exemple qui font de la première école de
rhétorique et de théologie qui échappent
à l'autorité de l'évêque abélard est
l'un des grands noms de la nouvelle
pensée médiévale mais surtout reste est
connu pour son histoire d'amour quelque
peu tragique avec héloïse l'une de ses
élèves
héloïse est d'ailleurs la première femme
à suivre un cursus d'art libéraux place
dans la catégorie maître en rupture avec
l'école de notre dame
on peut aussi citer guillaume de
champeaux qui font de l'école saint
victor parce que les étudiants réclament
et des raisons humaines et philosophique
et il leur fallait des explications
humaine et intelligible plus que des
affirmations ces nouvelles écoles sont
indépendantes et peut donc a priori y
avoir une vision beaucoup plus libre de
l'enseignement l'école d'abélard assiste
sur l'étude d'aristote ce qui était
grand mot oublié jusque là de manière
générale les élèves réclament de plus en
plus de débat de réflexion de
contestation mais 1168 quelle année
cette rupture n'est pas une exception
parisienne et n'est pas non plus
inédites
la première université de ce genre
nouveau est fondé à bologne en 1088 bien
sûr ces nouveautés ne plaisent dans un
premier temps pas trop à certains
religieux qui y voit une ingérence dans
leurs affaires
il traite ses nouveaux professeurs de
marchands de mots vu qu'à l'époque
c'était plutôt étudie la bible et
tétouan certains maîtres sont alors
accusé d'hérésie et excommunié aussi à
cause du fait que les enseignants
français cette langue vulgaire
place du la fin hérésie en effet on
dispute publiquement en violation des
constitutions sacré des mystères de la
divinité de l'incarnation du verbe
l'indivisible trinité est coupé et mis
en pièces au carrefour autant de docteur
autant d'erreurs autant d'auditoire
autant de scandales
autant de place publique autant de
blasphème ou xiiie siècle thomas d'aquin
fait carrément une comparaison entre la
foi catholique et la philosophie
d'aristote la création de l'université
au deuxième siècle permet donc une
petite renaissance qui n'a rien à envier
à celle du 15e siècle les savoir antique
sont de nouveau étudié des réflexions
sont menées sur la nature l'amour la
religion l'humanisme la physique la
métaphysique la politique d' anciens
maîtres ou étudiants écrivent aussi des
ouvrages plutôt connus comme les
légendes arthuriennes qui sont l'oeuvre
de geoffroy de mousse un ancien étudiant
d'oxford au xiiie siècle ces nouvelles
écoles commencent à obtenir quelques
privilèges
les maîtres sont exemptés de taxes et
des obligations militaires en 1200
permis de 115 et forme une cote de m ec
raismes le nom d'association des maîtres
et étudiantes de paris soit universitas
magisto romed scholar yom par jens une
université donc quelle horrible accent
c'est le même principe que les
corporations de métiers les maîtres
rédige des règles des statuts et
s'organisant différentes facultés studio
mais pour les plus jeunes il ya la
faculté des arts libéraux qu'on a déjà
présenté avec le preview et le quad
review puis peuvent se spécialiser dans
une faculté de théologie ni de droit
canonique de médecine etc
à la fin de chaque semestre au lieu des
examens et après cinq ou six années
d'études les élèves peuvent passer le
baccalauréat qui apparaît aussi au xiiie
siècle plein de mots connus donc une
fois leur bac en poche ils peuvent
commencer à travailler comme assistant
d'un mètre tout en préparant leur
licence ou leur doctorat la durée
variable selon les filières
12e siècle il fallait par exemple 15 ans
pour obtenir la licence de théologie pas
être pressé en 1231 le pape accorde des
privilèges à toutes les universités
européennes qui sont alors en pleine
expansion et fixent leur organisation
même si elles reçoivent ce coup de pouce
du pape elle reste indépendante de
l'église au niveau local c'est
d'ailleurs le pape qui est à l'origine
de la création de nombreuses universités
au xiiie siècle on compte une vingtaine
d'universités en europe
certaines comme celle de paris où
d'oxford son général et propose un grand
nombre de facultés
d'autres sont éphémères comme celle
d'angers ou spécialisés montpellier
devient ainsi renommé pour sa faculté de
médecine
toulouse pour celle de théologie et
c'est l'école de montpellier propose dès
la deuxième moitié du 12e siècle un
enseignement de médecine théorique sur
les causes des maladies et pratiques sur
les moyens de traiter ces maladies et
des dissections partir du 14 ème siècle
comme celle représentée ici
ouais enfin la médecine c'est pas la
discipline la plus prestigieuse à
l'époque paraît que les étudiants en
médecine sont juste là parce qu'ils sont
pas assez bons pour la philosophie bac s
sur côté chacune de ses facultés et
dirigée par un doyen et l'ensemble de
l'université et sous la direction du
recteur encore des termes dont l'emploi
est resté à peu près même jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
les cours sont partagés entre cours
magistraux colas yeux explication de
texte lectio et dispute ou discussions
quest younès par contre les universités
manque encore de locaux les maîtres loup
et même des salles où squattent même
parfois les églises le développement des
universités permet à de nombreux autres
métiers de s'installer dans le secteur
les copistes relieurs et libraires
s'installe en ville et permettent aux
universités de posséder des
bibliothèques de plus en plus riches
mais ça j'en ai déjà parlé dans la vidéo
sur les bibliothèques les ordres
mendiants franciscains et dominicains
sont au départ opposé à l'enseignement
des arts des bureaux mais il change
d'avis dès le 13ème siècle les ouvre à
paris des studios des écoles à vocation
plus religieuse que les universités mais
très bien réputé est doté de
bibliothèque très importante dans les
domaines de la philosophie la théologie
de l'art du sermon etc
mais du coup qui sont les élèves et qui
sont leurs profs
la plupart des étudiants sont de jeunes
clair aux futurs clair issu de la petite
noblesse
il porte alors la tonsure et ont le
statut d'ecclésiastiques on trouve aussi
des étudiants issus de la paysannerie
plus rares mais de manière générale les
étudiants sont plutôt en galère d'argent
comme aujourd'hui quoi certains doivent
travailler pour payer leurs études
demandé l'aide des parents voire
renoncer ou quitter rapidement
l'université pour exercer un vrai métier
ici un étudiant de 14 ans qui décide de
piétiner ses cahiers et d'entrer dans la
vie la vraie rebelle
d'autres étudiants al'inverse sont des
clercs déjà en poste et qui ont demandé
un congé à leurs évêques pour prolonger
leurs études un peu indéfiniment en
cours ils sont entre trois et une
vingtaine par classe et mélanger entre
tous niveaux
certains étudiants sont sérieux d'autres
peuvent fréquenter un peu trop les
tavernes surtout chez les étudiants en
lettres et devenir des golliard écrivant
des poèmes satiriques et des chansons à
boire
la bonne ambiance beaucoup d'étudiants
viennent aussi de loin puisqu'il existe
assez peu d'universités en europe cela
pose le problème du logement parce que
bach
n'est prévu pour eux au départ ils sont
parfois logés dans des cloîtres des
chambres louées mais qui coûte cher ou
chez leurs maîtres directement ce n'est
qu'au xiiie siècle qu'apparaissent les
collèges qui n'ont rien à voir avec ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui ce sont des
établissements fondés par des riches et
ou religieux qui permettent aux
étudiants de se loger pour pas cher mais
aussi de bénéficier d'une bibliothèque
d'un petit cloître pour étudier le plus
célèbre le collège du chanoine robert de
sorbon fondée en 1257 recoupent gueule
ça donne envie
il possède la meilleure bibliothèques de
paris et se transforme ensuite en
faculté de théologie puis en la sorbonne
que vous connaissez apparemment on peut
aussi citer le collège de forte fondée
en 1394 grâce au testament d'un chanoine
qui ordonne qu'il soit fondé un collège
de huit écoliers dans l'une des maisons
qu'il possédait à paris savoir la
première située rue des cordiers près
des frères prêcheurs la seconde située
au clos brunel et la troisième située
rue saint victor selon qu'il paraît très
convenable à son exécuteur testamentaire
aujourd'hui il en subsiste la tour
calvin que voici
au xvème siècle on trouve environ 50 de
ses collèges dans paris mais qui me
permet toujours de loger que 10% des
étudiants après leurs études et peuvent
devenir professeur au religieux ou
intégrer une cour princière ou
épiscopale
passons au maître maintenant au début
des universités ou 2ème siècle n'importe
quel maître pouvait enseigner sans avoir
à passer l'examen
vous prenez pour l'enseignant de quoi
plus de cap - capes les étudiants
choisissait alors leurs maîtres selon
leur réputation et les enseigner souvent
gratuitement en exerçant un autre métier
lié à leur discipline à côté souvent
c'était des religieux avec l'essor des
universités leur métier gagne en
reconnaissance le touche enfin un
salaire qui ne permet pas un niveau de
vie très élevé mais là encore rien
nouveau sous le soleil et peuvent se
faire aider de suppléants qui sont
souvent des étudiants de niveau licence
ou d'autant certains maîtres deviennent
très réputé comme abélard thomas d'aquin
ils peuvent rester mettre toute leur vie
poursuivre leur carrière en entrant au
service de prince ou de roi en tant que
précepteur ou que conseiller d'autres
finissent par se retirer dans un
monastère pour une retraite bien méritée
il existe aussi des rivalités entre m
l'anssi cité au 12e siècle le conflit
sanglant entre m arnoux d'andean émettre
une berder de mag qu'il décrit en ces
mots vous avez présentement chez vous un
professeur idiots qui me calomnie ne
cesse d'inventer des choses qu'on ne
devrait jamais dire contre un poète
corriger le c'est dans votre intérêt si
moi je ne démolit pas où ce n'est pas à
cause de lui mais par respect pour vous
que ce test donc sa lente maudite
autrement marie poste fera éclater au
grand jour sa stupidité
bref les universités apporte un bon
nombre de savoir et de réflexion qui
préfigure la renaissance et ironiquement
c'est au moment de cette renaissance
avec un grand r que les universités ne
sont plus vraiment au top
au xvème siècle le renseignement surtout
dans domaine de la théologie peine à se
renouveler ce que ça fait trois siècles
que les maîtres étudiants tourne autour
des mêmes textes se posent les mêmes
questions sans chercher vraiment évoluer
certaines universités passe alors sous
le contrôle de l'état ou de princes et
deviennent des centres de formation pour
futurs administrateurs du royaume
plutôt que des lieux de culture voilà
c'est tout pour cette épisode un peu
plus court que les précédents mais ça
fait du bien de temps en temps on se
retrouve à la fin du mois pour un jean
todt a bad a semé langue de mes passions
l'hydromel et les fajitas les femmes pas
d'assez les dinosaures
en attendant on partage et pousse bleuté
et ip à volonté au revoir
l'aimta vers aquand somme stanco à
moscou et c'est comme ça l'a clos d'un
procès à moscou et son père un soldat
guilad à tour de table ou bine au
beausset speech est ok stop aux squales
à tous les coups et rigueur déjà tour
quilano de l'abbé beaucoup et la mine
discret rêvez vous de ces lots de
coimbra tour il s est secoué par des
bombardements
queen-mary veste et un peu plus ses
locaux fédéraux ce témoin cette probable
comme étant une sorte m